respawn has announced the next limited
time event for apex legends is coming
March 3rd it's called system override
and will offer plenty of new content
some of which will stick around but most
of which will be gone after two weeks
keep watching to learn everything you
need to know about what's coming and
system over let's start with the limited
time step during system override you'll
have access to a new mode called deja
loot though the dropship path and ring
closure pattern will change day to day
in the new mode loot placement won't the
loot spawn is permanently set during
deja loot so if you happen to find a
perfectly outfitted triple take
somewhere you can rest easy knowing that
same triple take will spawn in that
exact spot for every match you play just
don't rest too easy chances are if you
know where all the best loot will spawn
your opponents will to dejah a loot will
take place on world's edge during the
first week of system override before
transitioning to king's canyon for the
second in deja loot you'll also find a
brand new piece of armor
the Evo shield this glowing body shield
starts out weaker than a common white
one but damaging enemies will allow it
to grow stronger at max strength the
evil shield surpasses an epic purple
body shield rivaling a legendary golden
respawn has said the Evo shield will
remain exclusive to dejah loot for now
but the team will consider adding the
armor to the main game based on player
feedback system override presents plenty
of limited time cosmetics to earn to
complete endgame challenges and you'll
move up in the prize trap allowing you
to unlock rewards
there are also 24 themed limited time
cosmetics that you can purchase through
Apex coins or crafting materials or earn
through special apex packs nab all 24
and you'll earn a Kane's heirloom a
butterfly knife that also acts as a stem
syringe permanent changes will be made
in system override - you want one of
those cool-looking character heirlooms
but you're scared that the rng gods will
curse you with the exact one you don't
want one system override starts you
don't have to worry about that instead
of randomly earning an heirloom from
opening apex packs players will instead
earn heirloom shards with these shards
you can construct whichever heirloom you
want whether you want Wraith bloodhound
lifeline or Pathfinder one system
override ends the octane heirloom will
be added to the pool to this heirloom
system will stick around even after
system overwrite ends and that's
everything there is to know about system
override ahead of the event are you
excited to see King's candy returned
once again are you curious as to the
effectiveness of the Evo shield let us
know in the comments section below
[Music]